Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still
blazing a trail
for those who take
their fate into their own hands.
Well, Sharks,
do I have a treat for you.
You got to stop
doing this right now.
What's the game plan
for world domination?
And I'm just sitting here
trying to find
a way I can could be
your partner.
I would love to see
if anyone else is interested.
‐This is how you thank me?
‐[ Laughs ]
Walk this runway.
Let's go.
There you go.
[ Laughs ]
I believe that
you could sell anything.
‐Bang‐tastic!
‐Bang!
You just became
a want‐repreneur.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a way to get to know
your feline friends better.
♪♪
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Hi, Sharks.
My name is Anna Skaya,
I'm the founder of Basepaws,
and this is my cat, Koko.
And today we're asking for
$250,000 for 5% of our company.
‐Wow.
‐So, I adopted Koko
at my local shelter,
and she stole my heart.
She sleeps in my bed,
eats my food, steals my socks,
and I think
she could read my mind,
but how much do
I really know about her?
Cats can't speak, but
their DNA speaks loud and clear.
‐Meow!
‐[ Chuckles ]
Basepaws is the world's
first DNA test for cats.
We give powerful insights about
your cat's ancestry and breed,
genetic traits, and disease.
And the more you know
about your pet,
the longer you will have
to love them.
We send you a cat kit
in the mail.
It has a swab
and some adhesive tape.
You put the tape on your cat,
whisk it off.
It's a little bit
like waxing your cat,
but it really
doesn't hurt them.
‐[ Laughs ]
We process the sample
in our lab,
and we send you back
a comprehensive report.
We can tell you if your cat
is part Persian
or part Maine Coon and
if it has any specific diseases
that you should
know about.
Just imagine what we can do
for animal health
with this type of database.
Our big mission at Basepaws
is to make the world
better for pets.
So, Sharks,
it's a hot space.
We're first to market.
We've got a great team.
The time to invest is meow.
[now]
‐Meow!
Anna, I think
it's really amazing that
you've adopted
a‐a starving actor.
[ Laughter ]
Anna, do you have
samples for us?
Yes, I do.
Thank you for asking.
Um...Koko!
Cuban: Put her
on your lap, Robert.
Come on! Aww!
Can you
please take two?
Thank you very much.
‐Thanks, Anna.
‐Thank you.
‐Yeah.
‐Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you.
‐Oh, it comes with a little toy.
Thank you, Koko.
Do you want to say "bye" now?
‐Bye, Koko.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Bye, Koko. Thank you.
O'Leary:
There's a swab in here.
I thought you tore out
the hair follicles.
Skaya: You do both.
So, sometimes your cat can be
a Sphynx cat,
which has no hair...
‐Right.
‐...so we have to send a swab.
‐But only for cats?
‐No, not only for cats.
We have big plans.
Next year, we're actually
launching a dog product.
We have a lot of interest
from people
to launch
a horse product.
There's no consumer
DNA test for horses.
But, Anna, isn't there
a consumer product for dogs?
You can
definitely do dogs.
There's two companies
that have...
It's just
a different test.
...been before us that are
doing a dog DNA product.
It's double the price
because they have a much
different technology,
which is kind of old‐school
and not as agile as ours.
So your unique factor
is the way you do it.
It's your technology.
Correct.
And one of
the biggest things for us
is to go beyond just
doing a consumer company,
like the cat kit,
and work with
nutrition companies.
Right.
The name of the game in
the pet space is nutrition.
Tell us how much it costs
to get the tests done.
‐It's a $95 product.
‐Whoa!
It costs $25
to make this test.
How long have you
been on the market?
10 months.
‐How many have you sold?
‐We've sold 2,500 cat kits.
We've had $200,000
in revenue.
We're gonna make $400,000
this year.
How much
have you raised?
‐We raised $350,000.
‐At what value?
It was a convertible note
on a $3 million cap,
and we built the whole company
on $350,000.
So, this is IP, R&D,
lab, everything.
For a biotech company,
it's, like ‐‐ it's amazing.
And you send it
out to a lab.
We have our own lab
here in Los Angeles,
so we do the whole process ‐‐
getting the DNA back,
extracting the DNA,
doing everything
ourselves.
Meaning you lease it or you
purchased all the equipment?
We're renting benches
the same way
you'd rent an office space.
How did you launch?
What was your mode
of selling?
So, we launched through
our website and on Instagram.
‐Instagram is ‐‐
‐That's it?
Oh, yeah,
it's made for us.
We make really funny,
cutesy ads with lots of cats.
People love it.
‐And what's your history?
How did you
get to this point?
So, Basepaws is
my fourth company.
Wow.
I founded a company
and sold it to Groupon.
I was the CEO
of Groupon Russia ‐‐
500‐person business.
This is what I do.
I build brands.
I graduated UCLA.
Both of my parents
are biologists.
Actually, I spent more time
at a laboratory
when I was a kid
than on a playground.
O'Leary: Anna, if you're
about to buy an expensive cat
like some rare
chocolate point Siamese
or something.
I used to live
with two of those things.
I really hated them.
‐[ Chuckles ]
But there's some
expensive breeds, right?
Skaya: Oh, absolutely.
I would love to tell you
how we work with breeders.
But could I take
the Basepaw test,
send it in,
find out if I have
a defective unit here or not?
That's exactly
what we're doing.
We're like the CARFAX report
for breeders,
especially
international breeders.
So, imagine you spend
$5,000 on the cat ‐‐
It's that much ‐‐
$5,000 for a cat?
Oh, of course.
But, Anna, I just want
to go back, though.
You're not the first
animal‐testing
DNA product, right?
We are the first company
that does this for cats.
In your technology,
could I send you
horse DNA,
and could you
do it today?
I can do it
by the end of next year.
And what do you have to do
different to get there?
Create a new pipeline,
create a new test
but with the same machines
that we have.
Listen, I love cats.
I'm a cat person,
but do you think that
people care more about
testing of their dogs
than they do their cats?
There's a lot more money
in the dog space.
The cat section
is, like, this tiny,
and the dog section
is the whole store.
Cats are underfunded,
understudied.
There's actually more cats
in the United States than dogs.
People don't spend money
on cats
because cats
are very protective.
They don't tell you
if they want something.
But for
the last 10 years,
things have really shifted
in the cat space.
Now there's people
walking cats.
You've probably seen this.
‐There's the cat cafés.
‐Cat cafés, thank you.
‐You can't walk a cat.
‐Oh, yes, you can.
‐Look, I'm interested.
I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I would do the $250,000
for 8.3%,
and I want 1.7%
in advisory shares.
That kind of puts you around
the $3 million valuation.
I add too much value.
I want something for it.
So 10%.
$250,000 for 5%
is basically
what the other investors
have come in with.
‐But they're not a Shark, Anna.
‐Anna, you can't come in here
and tell us
why we're not of value.
‐Oh, but you are.
‐Come on. I'm a Shark.
I mean,
I'm not just any money.
Yeah, but I would love you
as an advisor,
so I really like your deal.
‐Yeah?
But I would love to see
if anyone else is interested.
I'm sure they are,
but I'm giving you mine.
Greiner: Well, Anna,
I'll share with you.
You say you're going
to kill it this year,
but so far
in the 10 months,
you only sold
2,500 tests.
So, it doesn't give me
enough confidence
at this moment
in which to invest,
but I wish you good luck.
‐Thank you, Lori.
‐I'm out.
I was somewhat interested,
but my offer will be
nowhere near as generous
as I think Kevin's is,
so I'm out.
Mm.
Cuban:
Yeah, Anna, look,
I think what
you're doing is great,
but I think scaling's gonna be
a lot more difficult
in terms of what it takes
to do the labs at scale,
do all the testing
at scale,
so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
So, Robert?
So, Anna, I'm sitting here
listening to the other
Sharks drop out,
and I'm thinking,
"What are they missing?"
I'm amazed.
I'm jumping
up and down.
Why isn't everybody else
jumping up and down?
I love the technology.
A friend of mine's
a big horse broker.
You could charge
thousands for that test.
Yep, absolutely.
Kevin, what was your offer?
‐My offer is 8.3% for $250,000
plus 1.7%
advisory shares,
and I think I add
a lot of value,
so you should
consider that.
I'll make you
the same offer.
$250,000 for 10%.
Would you guys
do a deal together,
and would you
lower the equity?
There isn't enough.
Getting two Sharks
is a big deal.
It doesn't happen
very often.
I would do the deal with
Robert for the $250,000,
and we would
do it for 10%.
And we don't care
how do it,
whether it's common
or advisory shares,
'cause it's gonna be
subsequent rounds.
So, Kevin,
are we splitting the $250,000
so $125,000 each?
Yes, and you get 5%.
Okay.
You can do
the last points.
I would do that deal
with Kevin.
♪♪
$250,000, $125,000 each,
for 10%.
What do you say, Anna?
♪♪
‐Guys, let's do it.
‐All right!
O'Leary:
Hey, we're down.
It's because
I get both Sharks.
Thank you, sir.
Here, hug it out.
You're very impressive.
I'm really impressed.
‐I am so excited!
‐This should be ‐‐
I love your energy.
‐Congratulations.
‐Congrats.
Bye, guys, thank you.
♪♪
Robert and Kevin
are a bit of a yin and a yang.
One brings in the energy,
and the other brings in
a little bit of that cattiness,
and I think together
they make a perfect team for me.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up, an accessory
for the sharp‐dressed man.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Cedric Cobb.
I'm from
St. Louis, Missouri.
I'm the president and CEO
of Best Wardrobe Solutions.
I'm seeking
a $200,000 investment
for a 15% stake
in my company.
You know it's been said
that clothes make the man,
and truer words
have never been spoken.
But when a man is left
to a world of fashion,
he's lost.
But that's where I come in.
Take a look at these
good‐looking gentlemen
I brought in here
with me today.
Good‐looking suits,
nice‐looking ties,
but something's missing.
Well, it's all
in the details.
They need
a pocket square.
‐Yes!
‐It's an old accessory
with a century‐old
problem
of how to keep pocket squares
looking good all day.
So, I am actually
the inventor
of the best
pocket‐square holder.
Here is how it works.
You just simply style your
pocket square like so,
you insert
your pocket square
into the pocket‐square
holder like a clam.
Now, we simply insert
the pocket‐square holder...
...Bam!
Problem solved!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Voilà.
Cobb: Look at what
we have here.
So, Sharks, join me
in raising the self‐esteem
of men
all around the world.
Can we try one?
Can we see it?
Absolutely, you can.
All right,
so, listen.
We have some special styles
for you guys.
You have what's called
the Rose Fold.
You have the Signature Fold.
‐Thank you.
Cobb:
Mr. O'Leary, you're looking
at the Straight Fold.
What do you
think, Lori?
I think
it looks nice.
Real quick, I want to go ahead
and dismiss my guys.
Gentlemen,
thank you so much.
[ Chuckling ] I like that
on you, Kevin.
It looks like money.
Herjavec: Oh, that ‐‐ that
looks good, Kevin.
Cobb: Kevin, I think
I like that on you.
Yes!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Walk this runway. Let's go.
Let's go, Kev.
Ooh, la, la.
‐Okay.
‐That's style right there.
‐Put your shoulders back.
‐There you go!
‐Oh, nice, Kev, nice, Kev.
‐Stand up straight!
Cuban: Now you're killing
this pitch, Kevin.
Cobb: I don't think
he can stand up straight.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Work it, baby, work it!!
[ Laughs ]
This is the new thing
you need
for your 20
all‐the‐same suits.
‐Absolutely.
‐Just change your pocket square.
That's exac‐‐
Oh, my God.
‐Right?
‐I love you so much!
I hope you have
some sales, buddy.
Seriously, because he ‐‐
I don't need to do the pitch!
You got it!
[ Chuckles ]
O'Leary: Okay, let's get
to the numbers.
So, the product itself
retails for $19.99.
What does it
cost you to make?
It costs us
to make it $3.40.
‐Okay.
‐Have you sold any?
Yes, we've sold
52,000 of them.
‐Wow.
‐Whoa.
‐Good for you.
‐Is that lifetime?
That is ‐‐ That's lifetime.
So, we've been ‐‐
So, what's this year
gonna be in dollar sales?
$398,000.
That's still great.
Where are you selling them,
and how are you
selling them?
So, we actually sell them
on our website.
We sell them
through Amazon.
through Etsy.
We also do some
major events, as well.
So, like, church conferences,
uh, national conferences
for, like, urban leagues
and things of that nature.
And you have
a little booth there
and you're
selling them direct?
Uh, my booth is not little.
We actually ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
We try to do it big.
Look, I'm 6'5", 290 pounds.
I try to do everything big.
‐[ Laughs ]
We also wholesale
the product, too.
$7.50 is what
we wholesale it for.
‐Okay, it costs ‐‐
‐How much of your business ‐‐
the $398,000 ‐‐
is wholesale?
Wholesale is about
70% of our business?
Oh, okay, that changes
the dynamics.
Yeah.
Look. I think
it's a great business,
but at the end
of the day,
it's just wholesale
distribution of a good product,
and I just don't
see it as a fit for me,
so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you so much.
So, before we get
into everyone else,
I think it's really important
that you guys
get an opportunity
to meet
one of my newest
business partners,
and, uh, he's got
a couple cool words to say.
You may recognize him.
‐Oh, my.
Sharks, it's Ray Lewis.
‐Hey!
‐What's up, Ray?
I met Cedric Cobb,
and I tell you what.
To meet a man with his
integrity means everything,
but to see what he's done
for my fashion game
and with my confidence
when I put on a suit,
what I'm asking is
what Shark
will take the chance
to be a part of something
that becomes legendary ‐‐
the return
of the gentleman?
I'm glad I partnered
with Cedric.
I'm glad we spent
a lot of time together.
It's gonna be
an amazing ride.
Best pocket square
in America.
‐There you go.
‐The legend.
Greiner:
All right, wait...
Cobb:
So, Ray and I have ‐‐
Tell me who the legend is.
I can't ‐‐
I may seem stupid,
but I don't know.
No, it's okay.
So, Ray Lewis actually
just got enshrined
into the Pro Football
Hall of Fame.
He's most notable
for how inspirational he is.
He's a guy that really
understands
the imagery of things
and how, you know ‐‐
Daymond, I even
seen some things online
where you talked about
the importance of
attention to detail
in how we look.
And growing up, also,
an African‐American kid
in a neighborhood
where people don't necessarily
take you seriously
until you look
a certain way,
this has kind of
become a staple for me.
‐Cedric.
‐Yes, ma'am?
Do you run the company
by yourself?
No, I do have
a small team.
So, I have 10 seamstresses
that work for us
that ‐‐ that are kind of
spread out all over St. Louis,
and they do
piecemeal work for us.
Oh, so you make this
in the U. S. A.
Yeah, in the U. S. A.
Matter of fact,
my mother is my director
of product development.
You could cut your cost
dramatically on this.
You know that?
‐I'm so glad you said that,
because that's
what we're gonna use
a portion of the money for,
okay.
Yeah.
We can drive our cost down
by about 40%
by taking
all of our operations,
bringing it into
one wheelhouse,
and making it
all assembly‐line work
instead of
piecemeal work.
You know, Cedric,
I never thought
you'd be selling
$400,000 worth
of pocket‐square holders.
‐Yeah.
I mean,
kudos to you.
‐Thank you. Thank you.
‐You've done an amazing job.
It ‐‐ It's not
a business for me.
I think
it's too niche.
Congratulations to you.
‐Thank you so much.
It's just not for me.
I'm out.
Awesome, thank you
for your time.
O'Leary: You know, Cedric,
if I got behind this
and added this
to my...look,
it would just
take it to the moon.
I believe it, 'cause you'd be
a great project for me.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know,
I basically ‐‐
Yes, because the only difference
would be his pocket square.
[ Laughs ]
These Sharks don't understand
fashion branding.
That's what I'm all about.
Now, this ‐‐
the problem is
52,000 units ‐‐
it's a very small business.
There's nothing wrong
with it.
If I get behind this thing
and make it part of
my accoutrements, my look,
it's gonna be
a big deal.
This is how
I'd do this deal.
I give you
the $200,000.
This is a pure royalty play ‐‐
no equity for me.
I get a $1.50 a unit,
and I get behind it.
♪♪
How ‐‐ How long does
the $1.50 last?
How long are you bleeding him
for a $1.50 per unit?
How long
are you gonna be alive?
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Kevin has offered Cedric
$200,000
for a royalty of $1.50
per unit sold
for his men's fashion
accessory company,
Best Wardrobe Solutions.
I would do that deal
and make it part of my look.
I'd be handing this out
to all the guys I work
with on television.
How long does
the $1.50 last?
How long are you bleeding him
for a $1.50 per unit?
How long
are you gonna be alive?
[ Laughter ]
Cobb: I plan on living
to a healthy 90.
So you want $1.50
in perpetuity?
You got it.
And you keep the equity.
You control the company.
You decide to sell one day,
that's cool,
but I ‐‐
everywhere I go,
I'll make sure
the guys I work with
get one of these.
I'll be handing them out
all over the place
and explain to them,
"It's part of my look now."
That's powerful, buddy.
Very.
Okay, thank you, Kevin.
It's an offer.
So, here's my, um ‐‐
my thought process.
I'm sitting here
saying,
"Okay, well,
where can I add value?"
It can't be sales,
'cause you're doing amazing.
"Maybe I can take this thing
and light it up a little bit,"
but then all of a sudden...
[ Chuckles ]
...Ray Lewis comes on.
I just don't see a place
that I add value,
and I'm just sitting here
trying to find a way
I could be your partner.
I just will not add
any value to you,
so, for that reason,
I'm out.
‐Wow, okay.
Listen,
I was trying to think, you know,
how could I add value,
bring help.
I could help you bring the cost
down on the product.
Yeah.
But I do think that,
to Kevin's point ‐‐
oh, God ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
...that he could be
helpful in, you know,
wearing it,
being a fashion something.
A brand ambassador,
Lori.
A brand ambassador.
‐He's gonna hurt the image!
So...
I‐I feel like he has
a good offer there to you.
I don't think that
I would be giving you
a better offer.
So, I'm out.
Herjavec: All right,
you're down to Kevin.
And then there's one.
What are you
gonna do, big guy?
You do look good
in that, Kevin.
So, we talk about
the $1.50 in perpetuity.
Would you be able
to assist me
with going to
a Men's Wearhouse.
Okay, so
I'm gonna go everywhere.
I'm gonna call up
everybody,
and I'm going to also
be handing this out
to a lot of people that
I know in business saying,
"Look, I've made
this my solution.
Here's why it works."
I'm incentivized
to sell it
because I'm getting
a little piece
on every transaction.
‐Sure.
‐That works.
Cedric, come back
with a counter.
‐There's no counter.
‐Tell him what works.
Look, I want to sell
a million of these units
so I can make $1.5 million.
Here's what you do.
You say to him ‐‐
"Can you get down the cost
on the product?" Right?
Of course I can.
Get down the cost
on the product,
and then the $1.50
won't hurt.
It is a lot
more justified at that.
Volume reduces cost.
Now, I didn't hear if you said
you were okay going offshore,
because this could be
manufactured
for a fraction
of what you're paying.
This could be made
for under two bucks,
maybe even under
a dollar.
Well, actually,
here in the States,
just with
the investment itself,
we're gonna drive
the cost down to $2.04.
Yeah, but it could be
significantly cheaper.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐That's true.
I think you should
keep it in America
and give me that same deal
for a dollar royalty.
♪♪
I'll take that deal.
Oh!
[ Cheers ]
‐I want it.
‐There you go.
‐Outstanding!
‐Oh, my God.
And we made him look bad
all at the same time.
That's awesome.
Whoo!
Yeah!
Dreams ‐‐ [ Laughs ]
Sounds so cliché,
but dreams really do come true.
This is definitely
the American Dream.
Herjavec: Daymond, were you
always gonna do it,
or did you just
have enough of O'Leary,
and you said,
"Enough is enough"?
I‐I was in the middle,
and I was trying to find a way
that I can add value to him
as a partner,
and I figured if I can undercut
O'Leary right now,
save him money,
keep it in America,
I just added value.
‐That's a win.
The point is, though,
you don't have the creativity
to structure the deal.
‐But, Kevin,
you don't have the ability
to close those deals.
[ John laughs ]
Congratulations, Sharks,
on 10 amazing seasons.
You certainly
did change my life,
and you've changed the lives
of so many entrepreneurs.
So many exciting things
have happened
since I last saw you guys,
but the thing
I'm most excited about
is that Sanaia is going to be
at Walmart this summer
and groceries
all over the country.
Yay!
♪♪
Narrator: Next in the Tank
is a former "Shark Tank"
entrepreneur
who is returning
and hoping to redeem himself.
♪♪
Hello again, Sharks.
My name's Jason Woods
from Pleasant Hill, California,
and I'm back
in the Tank today
seeking $250,000
for a 5% stake
in my company...
‐Wow.
...Kymera Body Board ‐‐
the world's first all‐electric,
jet‐propelled body board.
‐No way.
‐Now, as you may remember,
my last lap around the Tank
didn't go so well.
Let's take a painful trip
down memory lane.
Um, I started this whole thing
about 10 years ago,
and, basically, I'm as far
as I can go on my own.
Greiner:
But these are prototypes.
You don't have
a product to sell yet.
Correct.
Cuban: Jason, you're not
an entrepreneur.
You're
a want‐repreneur.
10 years,
you couldn't figure out
how to go and get a product
and sell it.
Find somebody else
to run the business,
but it's not gonna be me.
I'm out.
John: I'm gonna give it
to you straight.
It's the worst pitch
I've ever seen.
I'm out.
♪♪
‐Whoops.
‐Wow.
‐Some strong opinions there.
You love punishment.
You love it.
But I got to use
my want‐repreneur line,
so I was happy.
Greiner: Oh, my gosh...
Go ahead, Jason.
...and to walk
back in here ‐‐
Woods: Well, all I have
to say is
you were right.
I took everything you said,
as brutal as it was.
I quit my job.
I threw aside
the want‐repreneur attitude.
And, Mark, you said
I should find somebody
to help me run the company.
Well, I did.
Hey, Adam.
Majewski:
Hey, Jason.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Adam Majewski,
and I handle the operations
for Kymera Body Board.
We took the garage prototype
that you saw last time
and evolved it into
something truly remarkable.
[ Rock music plays ]
Herjavec: Wow.
We now have
a fully‐refined product
that's ready to scale
and hit the market.
Oh, and we didn't
stop there.
♪♪
Our proprietary modular
drivetrain
can be adapted into
all sorts of vehicles.
How about a hybrid
electric kayak?
Paddle when you want,
motor when you don't.
Greiner: Wow.
That's cool.
Or maybe an electric jet
surfboard's more your style.
‐That's cool.
Why wait for the perfect wave
when you can make your own?
And if you've got an eye for
real performance,
how about an all‐electric
micro‐personal watercraft
that's in a class
all its own?
♪♪
From our backlog
of orders
to our booming
rental locations
to our international
distribution
to our rescue
operations,
Kymera's allowing people
to access the water
like never before
and setting the bar
for true electric watersport.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to put the past behind us
and jump into a fun,
profit‐filled future
on the water together?
We gave you nothing.
You spent a ton of money.
Where did you get it?
‐[ Chuckles ]
I've got this.
We've raised to date
about $625,000.
We've raised it
through several rounds
with different
investment groups,
ranging in valuations from
$2 million to $7.5 million.
‐How'd you find Adam?
‐So, what happened was,
while it was airing,
meaning the live episode,
I actually called him up
on the phone.
He's with his family
answering a phone call,
and I said,
"This is what I'm gonna do."
We've got sales, marketing,
distribution taken care of,
outlined the process,
and, over the next couple
of days, weeks,
we finalized a deal.
What made you
so interested
after you saw
that beating that he took?
So, I saw the product,
and I said,
"I want it, I know
other people want it,
and I can see a market
for this product,"
and I felt the Sharks
possibly got it wrong.
‐Yeah.
‐Reached out to him ‐‐
The Sharks are
never wrong, Adam, damn it.
The Sharks
are never wrong.
John: Okay, so ‐‐ so, Jason,
uh, you know,
we ‐‐ we beat you down.
You said
we'd helped you, right?
You come back and ask
for $250,000 for 5%.
This is
how you thank me?
[ Laughter ]
Thank God
you like me, right?
Imagine if you were mad at me.
‐Jason, how much does it cost?
How much does it cost?
The product sells
between $3,250 and $3,750
based on accessories.
‐Which product, Adam?
Which product?
‐$3,250.
Is everything about
the Kymera board
that's in
the black and white there?
That's what is fully done,
and that's what
we're talking about.
That's what
Yeah, correct.
Body Board is what's
currently available.
And, Jason,
how much is the Body Board?
It retails
for about $3,500.
‐$3,5000.
‐That's a lot of smackolas.
And a typical jet ski can vary
anywhere from, like, what?
The start at about $7,000,
range up to about $15,000.
Okay, so much
less expensive.
‐Yes.
‐What's your cost to make one?
About $1,800.
O'Leary: That's not
so good for margin
if you have two tiers
of distribution.
Correct.
So, I'm gonna make
the assumption.
I want one, okay, and I buy
lots of stuff for my lighthouse.
I want to see Kevin
on one of these things.
What's the game plan
for world domination?
So, first off, we have
direct‐to‐consumer sales,
and we'll set that aside
for right now.
We just signed a deal
four weeks ago
with one of the largest
luxury‐boat manufacturers
in the world, and
they're giving us access
to all 225
of their dealers
that will start carrying
this product out the door.
‐How many did they order?
‐The open house
with all their dealers
is July 29th.
So you don't have
the orders yet.
Correct.
This all comes down
to cash management, right?
So, you've raised
$625,000.
When was the last time
you raised money?
How much? How much do you
have in the bank?
$625,000.
The last raised was
the $7.5 million valuation.
What will sales be this year
with everything you know?
‐We're projecting $2 million.
‐But you've sold none so far.
No, we've sold
$350,000 year‐to‐date.
We've sold $900,000
in the last 12 months.
Woods: The biggest problem
we have right now
is we've never had
any inventory,
so everything we have sold
is at least three months out.
O'Leary: So, let's say
you do $2 million.
What will the company make
on the $2 million in sales?
On the $2 million,
$600,000.
That's after you pay
yourselves something?
No, that's top line,
so we're looking
at about 17%‐20%,
which falls in line
with boat manufacturing.
I'm trying to figure
out as an investor
how I get paid back.
You're basically telling me
you're worth 5 million bucks,
but you're basically gonna break
even on $2 million in sales.
Herjavec:
Adam, isn't this exactly what
he said to you last time?
Is it like
a rewind button?
Greiner:
No, but he's a lot happier
standing here today.
I mean,
the reality is
we're in a very
different place now
than we were
back then for sure.
Agreed, but why are you
worth $5 million?
One important thing ‐‐
the reason we built
these other prototypes
is because this is
a scalable technology.
So, this right here took me
12 years to get to work.
I built each one of those
in two weeks.
Wow.
John:
So, you have sales,
and you have distribution.
What do you need our money
and/or our help for?
It's inventory.
I mean, that's where
we've been stuck.
I'll make you an offer,
but my biggest concern
is this thing
just sucks cash.
I'll never get
my capital back.
But here's the only way
I would structure it.
I'll give you
the $250,000.
I want 5%
of the company,
but I want to get paid back
500 bucks a board...
[ Chuckles ]
...until I get back $750,000.
‐[ Laughs ]
Now, if you don't like it,
Mark, let's see you step up.
$500?!
No, it's just
your logic, Kevin.
It's just
I don't want
to hear a lot of noise
from the peanut gallery.
‐[ Laughs ]
Um, why don't you just
say, "Uh, no."
‐Um...
‐I wouldn't say "no"
until you know
you have another offer.
I have another offer
for you.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Jason and Adam have an offer
on the table from Kevin
for their personal
watercraft company, Kymera,
but Daymond
is also interested.
I have another offer
for you.
So, I'll offer you
$250,000 for 10%,
and I will handle and deal
with the factoring,
the licensing,
and that area.
'Cause I think that's
how you're gonna scale.
That's a better deal
than I would do. I'm out.
That's a crazy deal.
You should do mine.
Why would you give up
that much equity?
Herjavec:
Adam, I love the product.
I love this kind of cool,
funky, go‐fast stuff,
but I got to tell you ‐‐
you got to stop doing this
right now,
'cause this is cash burn,
this is defocus.
Got to sell
a lot of these.
Yeah, and my intent always
with the kayaks ‐‐
there's so many great
kayak manufacturers out there.
I don't need to be
a kayak manufacturer.
You can drown
in opportunity
when you're starting
a business, as you know.
Right, right.
Absolutely. So ‐‐
O'Leary: Is there an offer in
this lecture for you, Robert?
Well, I thought I'd lecture
for a little while here.
Listen, I'm very impressed
with your determination,
your drive, and, uh, I think
it's great what you've done.
Thank you, Lori.
It's not the right
investment for me,
so I'm out.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
O'Leary:
Robert, back to you.
Love it.
Love the second chances.
I mean, that's one of the things
that makes this country great.
Everybody deserves
a second chance.
So, Kevin's offer was
he's gonna give you money ‐‐
$250,000 for 5%
of the company.
I get $500 a unit
until I recoup the $750,000.
So when you bankrupt them,
how are you gonna
get your money?
‐They're not gonna go bankrupt.
‐Yeah, like...
‐We would have no money.
‐Are you just making noise,
or are you gonna
make an offer?
Herjavec: Oh, come on.
Daymond,
what was your offer?
Yeah, and my offer
is $250,000 for 10%.
My interest is to add
the value for licensing
and finding him
the right factors,
the things
they need to scale.
I know this space.
I think you need more money.
I'll give you
$500,000 for 10%.
♪♪
‐Yes! Like, yes. Yes! Yes.
‐Done!
[ Laughter ]
‐My man!
‐Oh, my God!
Adam, such a pleasure
to meet you.
I love it!
‐Congratulations.
‐I appreciate it.
‐Good job.
‐Wow!
[ Adam laughs ]
That was
the right partner.
[ Laughs ]
That was exactly
who we wanted.
Woods: "Redemption" is
the only word you can use.
You know,
if you're willing to give
everything that you've got
to what you believe in,
you can make it happen,
but it may take a long time,
and it may be harder
than you think,
but it's totally worth it
in the end.
Robert, you just became
a want‐repreneur.
[ Laughs ]
A moment of silence for
$500,000 that just died.
Silence for the $500,000.
‐Oh, my God.
Narrator: Earlier this season,
we had our first "Shark Tank"
High School Sweepstakes
to inspire high school kids
across the country
to be entrepreneurs.
Four students won
a video‐chat session
with their favorite Shark...
Hey, Hudson.
You're someone I've looked up to
for, like, so many years.
I'm all yours.
Whatever you need
from me, buddy.
Thank you so much
for all the information.
...and one student won
the grand prize ‐‐
a trip to visit the Sharks
on the set
during a taping
of "Shark Tank,"
and there was
an extra special surprise.
[ Student chanting
"Shark Tank" ]
Cuban: Some of us Sharks decided
to visit Boca Raton, Florida,
to meet Madison,
the grand prize winner
of our "Shark Tank"
High School Sweepstakes.
We also brought along
the Junior Library Guild,
and Zoobean, one of my early
"Shark Tank" investments,
to gift educational software
and books to Madison's school.
We're donating to your school
in her name
over 1,000 new books
for your school library.
We're going to give our
software mobile app for free.
Burke: Now what you've all
been waiting for ‐‐
we're gonna have
a question‐and‐answer session
for the Sharks.
What inspired you
to become who you are today?
Well, Boca Raton
inspired me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Webb: This high school
is really special to me
'cause I actually attended it.
I feel like being here today is
gonna inspire these students
and make them feel
like they can do anything.
What advice do you have
for small‐business owners
in their first year
of operation?
What types of
marketing strategies
help expand and grow
your business?
True entrepreneurs
start out seeing that
there's a problem
that nobody is addressing.
Cuban: It doesn't matter
how many times you fail.
Sometimes you just
got to go for it.
We want you to take
our seat over one day.
That's the whole plan.
O'Leary:
We want kids to know
that they can control
their own destiny
by focusing on
their own futures,
making their own decisions,
and becoming entrepreneurs.
I want to thank you guys for
coming and, of course, Madison.
Madison:
I'm a huge "Shark Tank" fan,
and getting to meet the Sharks,
watching them speak,
it has been such
an amazing experience.
Cuban:
The beauty of "Shark Tank"
is that anybody
can start a company.
Doesn't matter
where you grew up,
the situation your family's in.
Doesn't really even matter
what kind of business.
It can be big or be small.
But you have a chance
to be on "Shark Tank,"
and who knows
what can happen from there.
All you have to do
is take that first step,
and anything is possible.
All: "Shark Tank"!
[ All cheering ]
Hadley: Try this.
Hadley:
My name is Jason Hadley,
and I live in Miami, Florida.
I've had a tough life.
Growing up, my mom
was on food stamps, welfare.
When I was 8 years old,
it's when it really got bad,
and we ended up
losing our house.
My mom struggled,
but she did what she could
to make sure we ate.
When I was 15 years old,
I found out my girlfriend
was pregnant.
There was no question
I was gonna raise my son.
I was gonna be there, and I was
gonna show him a real father.
Something I never had.
At this point in time,
I was doing a lot of bad things,
and my son saved my life.
If I did not
have my son at that age,
I'd be either locked up or dead.
I ended up being
the first male in my family
to graduate high school.
I found out I had
a real knack for sales.
I sold computers, I sold cars,
I sold furniture,
and I excelled at it all.
Pretty soon,
I'm gonna be able to sit down
and let you take over.
Today my son, Jaylon,
is my best friend.
He said, "You have so much
positive energy,
and this business allows you
to utilize all your skills."
Get some
of that in your life.
I decided
to invest in myself.
My life has showed me
that resiliency
can help you
to overcome any obstacles.
♪♪
‐I am so hungry.
‐I hope it's what I think.
It better be food.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks!
My name is Jason Hadley,
and I'm seeking
an $80,000 investment
for 20% stake in my business,
The Bang Shack,
and my product,
that world‐famous
Chicken Bang Dip.
Greiner: [ Chuckles ]
Hadley: Now, I know
what you're thinking ‐‐
"What is Chicken Bang Dip?"
That's what
I was thinking.
Well, Sharks,
do I have a treat for you.
Yeah!
I came up with this
chicken‐y, cheesy,
saucy, spinach‐y,
scrum‐diddly‐umptious dip
that will keep folks
coming back for more.
In short, you can
put this Bang on anything!
‐Mm, I like to bang things.
‐Anything!
I put it on rice, pasta,
vegetables, a burrito.
I even put it
on my omelette.
[ Laughter ]
Now, some people
don't eat chicken.
No problem!
I have a vegetarian version
that I use zucchini in
instead of chicken.
‐No!
‐And guess what.
‐What?!
‐What?
It's Bang‐tastic!
‐Bang!
‐Now...
Ba‐bang!
...maybe you don't
eat cheese.
I got you covered.
I have a vegan version
that my wife makes
the cheese from scratch
out of cashews!
‐Cashews?!
‐Yes, sir!
‐Really?
Now, there is no question
that this is popular,
and one thing
I know for sure ‐‐
you could help me
get this Bang Dip
in every door,
every store!
Bring people together
like never before!
[ Laughter ]
So, Sharks,
who wants to get
this Bang in your life?!
‐Let's Bang!
‐Yes!
‐Yes! [ Laughs ]
‐Bam!
‐Wow. Wow.
‐Ba‐bang!
‐Yeah!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐He needs more energy.
‐Whoo!
‐How you feeling?
Am I gonna
be excited, Jason?
Oh, yes, sir.
And I know you're a gentleman,
so I'll give you Lori's.
‐Oh, thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐There you go.
‐I'm gonna bang 'em all.
[ Laughter ]
All right,
here you go, Daymond.
Cuban: Let's bang.
Oh, Mark, you're gonna
love this.
Bring it. Bring it.
I see the stadium
written all over.
‐All over.
‐Oh, that's good.
‐Mmm. It's good.
‐Yeah.
Oh, it's good.
It's got a little buffalo
in the Bang.
That little kick
lets you know you're alive.
Herjavec: There's some garlic
in there.
‐Ooh!
‐That was Bang‐tastic.
‐Oh, that's so good!
‐Yes, sir.
Where are you
selling this?
In the farmer's market
in Florida.
That's all you're doing
today with it?
Good for you.
Right now,
we're building up
on farmer's markets
to get the name out there.
And, with it being
a fresh product,
you know, we figured
that was a good way
to get the name recognition,
brand recognition.
Jason, that presentation
was amazing.
It was great,
one of the best ever.
Thanks, Daymond.
Appreciate it, guys.
John: Talk about yourself,
'cause I want to know
where that all come from.
Okay.
'Cause we need to buy
some time so we can eat.
‐All right.
‐Right.
Well, I came from,
um, a large family.
My dad wasn't there.
You know, we were raised
by my mom,
and, uh, we didn't have much,
so I always, you know,
felt that it was my job
to take care of the family.
So, I'd get out, mow lawns,
you know, go sell candy bars,
newspapers.
I found out
I was real good at sales.
You know, went through
a lot of things,
had my son at 15,
you know, but all ‐‐
‐You had a son at 15?
‐Yes, but it ‐‐
it was a blessing.
He gave me another reason,
you know, to push,
you know, to wake up
in the morning
not just for me but for him.
And I've done well at sales.
And after being in sales,
you know,
and making so much
for other people,
I had this dip
that I'd put together,
and I'd bring it
to any type of get‐together.
They're like,
"J, bring the Bang!"
‐"Bring the Bang."
‐You know, so I'd bring it.
They'd be blown away,
and I'm like,
"Man, I'm gonna do
something with this."
So, me and my wife,
we went
to the farmer's market.
We set up a booth,
two crock pots.
We sell out
every single weekend.
‐People are trying it, right?
‐Wow.
Oh, yeah.
They sample it,
they try it, they buy it.
Like, you're making it
right there.
Right there.
Right now,
we have a larger booth,
and we have 12 crock pots,
and people come line up.
How much have you sold
over the last year?
January 2017
till the end of the year,
we did $53,000,
and this is at
one farmer's market!
That's crazy.
This is two days
out of the week.
Can they buy it online
or anything?
Not yet, and I have my website
all the way done,
but doing that
out of my crock pots ‐‐
that's why I came
to you guys.
Greiner: What do you do
the rest of the week?
Search engine optimization,
marketing.
Why is your website
not up and running yet?
Oh, it is.
Okay.
I have the website
all up and running.
Why have you
chosen not to sell then?
Yeah, why haven't you
done that?
Because, again,
I'm selling out of crock pots.
Like, to ship that
all over the country
out of crock pots ‐‐
Or you just put it in
the same type of containers.
Yeah.
‐Right, but ‐‐
‐Well, you have to learn that.
You have to learn
how to do that.
To make it
more in bulk,
you know,
to handle that business.
You know, right now, we started
at a second farmer's market.
That's why we should
be making $88,000
by the end of the year.
‐Wow.
‐Really?
O'Leary:
What's the game plan for you
here today on "Shark Tank"?
What's the big plan?
I'm going to get
a commercial kitchen
where I make it
more in bulk,
but also, I want
to get it in stores.
How do you package it?
Do you have one here?
Uh, not out here.
♪♪
Look, the refrigeration
department
is a different challenge
because that real estate
is very competitive,
and so they already have
dips like this,
but you don't have the
infrastructure to do this.
You have to create it.
I'm looking at it
saying to myself,
"What do I do with this?
Do I want to go to work,
go down there
and meet with the buyers,
explain how we're
gonna support this on social
and try and roll it out
and get the co‐packer going,"
or are you gonna
do all that work?
I will do it.
You get me
in front of the people,
you don't have to do that work.
I'm good at sales.
I'm good with people,
face‐to‐face, closing deals.
That's what I've done.
Then why haven't you
done that, Jason?
You are good at sales.
You did a great
presentation today.
Yeah 'cause
that's the scary part.
All the skill you have,
great product,
and you would think you would
have figured these things out
to get it so that
you had a product,
you had a jar
already in place.
The reality is, you're
looking for that person
to help you
formulate everything
to get the right packaging,
to help you really
turn it into a product
and into a company,
and that's just
a lot of work right now.
I do have the packaging,
though, Mark.
Not to interrupt you.
‐But you didn't bring it here.
‐I have my labels. I have ‐‐
You didn't
bring it here.
You know, we have
no way of seeing it.
And so
congratulations, man.
I'm a huge Jason fan.
Keep on selling.
But for right now,
I have to say I'm out.
‐Thank you, Mark.
‐Congrats, man.
‐Thank you.
John:
You know, even if you
put it in stores,
how do you get them
moved off the shelf
is my biggest challenge.
You're gonna have to do
countless trunk shows
and bring you there
every day.
You can't be
everywhere.
For that reason,
I'm out.
I‐I respect that,
Daymond.
Here's the thing.
You know,
I love the dip,
and I believe that
you could sell anything.
You have a very charismatic
personality that people like.
I wish you luck,
but right now,
it's too early for me,
so I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Jason, you came here
too early.
I don't need a job.
What I need to do
is use my leverage
to make more money
with you.
This isn't
investable, yet.
I'm out.
Thank you, Kevin.
♪♪
Yeah, you know,
uh, Jason,
there's a transition
between being a salesman
and being
a business guy.
If you had
a package with you...
‐Yes.
‐...if you would've said, "Look,
I've had a test run
in this store," I'm gonna say
I think you would've got
an investment today.
You had a kid at 15.
I can't imagine the pressure
and responsibility of that.
I mean, that's real life
responsibility.
If you can do that,
you can learn this.
‐Yes.
You're gonna fail,
and you're gonna get
knocked down,
but you just got to keep going.
You just got to keep going.
You'll do it.
For now I'm out.
Thanks, Robert.
Thank you.
I appreciate it, guys.
‐Good luck, Jason.
‐This is really good.
‐Thank you.
‐Just heart‐breaking,
you know.
The amount of work
that it would take
to get this launched...
There's just so much work.
Unbelievable.
Herjavec:
You know, that's the problem.
After 10 years,
you learn how much work it is.
Hadley: I've given it everything
that I have, and it's mine.
It's not gonna stop.
I'm gonna keep going.
You know, this Bang Shack train
is not stopping.
♪♪